for abstract paintings named in memory
of Nazi Germany's biggest concentration
camp Auschwitz Birkenau everyone who
visits the German Bundestag will pass
these works when they enter the building
but is it possible to convey the horrors
of the Holocaust through art music is a
good example instrumental music where
the title suggests what the song is
about and the music reflects that
hopefully that's what I've managed to do
with these paintings the works are based
on four photographs smuggled out of
Auschwitz where more than a million Jews
died these photos are the foundation of
which dust paintings he worked on the
series in 2014
typical of his style the layers of paint
are scraped and squeegees suggestions of
smoke and ash
the 85 year old painter donated copies
of his piece to the Bundestag as a
symbol of how Germany deals with its
dark past the entrance lobby now hosts
two of his creations he celebrated as
one of the world's most important
contemporary artists of course these are
abstract paintings as well but behind
these abstract paintings there's a very
concrete project the debate about a part
of German history that cannot be erased
nora suppress vista says he's glad for
decades he wanted to look at Auschwitz
as an artist the result will be an
abstract memorial scene by each and
every visitor to the German Bundestag
[Applause]